I'm in my wardrobe room here at Televisa,
I'm on the soap opera.
Telenovela.
Yes.
Mi Adorable Maldicion, which would be like "Lovely Curse".
Is it, it's Nacho, yes?
Nacho.
And I specifically asked if I could play the role
of a very sexy man who has a steamy encounter
with a very beautiful Mexican woman.
Yes.
You guys said "No problem", and came back to me,
and I play a cheese merchant.
That's it, that's true.
(laughing)
I'm selling cheese, and I don't get the woman.
What happened?
Well...
What happened...
The thing is that...
That's all I need to hear.
(laughing)
You did it, that's all you need to say.
Nacho, give me a little bit of the backstory--
This is a girl that they mistakenly think
that she's evil,
and she grows up, she becomes a beautiful girl--
And is there any chance that she will love my character?
I think so, yes.
(laughing)
For God's sake.
Does she or doesn't she?
We'll take Rodrigo, which is happens to be--
Is Rodrigo her lover?
Her boyfriend.
But we can kill him in the story, and then bring in the--
(laughing)
You'll kill Rodrigo for me?
Well yeah sure!
This is fantastic!
We're gonna turn this whole telenovela upside down!
Yes, that's correct.
So who's gonna tell Rodrigo he's dead?
You better go tell him.
Well, Richard, why don't you go and--
(laughing)
(violin playing)
(applauding and cheering)
(laughing)
(laughing and applauding)
(cheering and applauding)
(laughing)
No, no no no no!
(cheering and applauding)
(laughing)
(laughing and applauding)
(cheering and applauding)